hello everyone it has an enormous
survival horror fan it is my favorite
video game genre and has been for a very
long time I took an unfortunately poorly
timed week off last week I didn't make
any videos
um I was overseas uh and there was
content from both Resident Evil and
Silent Hill
um so I have avoided pretty much all of
it thankfully
um I I saw a few vague reactions to some
Silent Hill stuff but I haven't actually
watched anything or seen anything
concrete so instead of watching the full
conferences or the full showcases I
thought that I would actually just watch
the trailers right now so we're going to
watch the Resident Evil 4 second trailer
the Resident Evil reverse launch trailer
the Resident Evil Village Gold Edition
story trailer and then whatever there is
for Silent Hill um and also for people
who maybe won't be finishing this video
uh I actually have early access to
the uh
Village DLC so I will have gameplay up
of that very very soon which I am
excited to share with you all
um okay let's jump into it I'm going to
start with I know I'm sure they showed
this at the end but I'm going to start
with re4 of course let me
reframe this real quick
all right ready to go in crispy crispy
4K let's do it I feel like I love
watching these because
[Music]
like Resident Evil has done such a good
job
of making it so that these remakes
are actually like a properly fresh
experience which is very needed for re4
which has been re-released a million
times and I just played on Oculus or
meta or whatever
they're making them fresh
you're here looking for someone
maybe it's amazing senorita
Ashley
where are you I wonder if they fixed the
Spanish
your soul
oh my God
Ashley Graham are you in here
just let me go listen
here in the president's borders
what is that
what do we do a lot of Slams are
escaping we need to go
I'm Gonna Get You
you can stop right there
Ada
a lot of this is
my faithfulness
what's happening to me
now
abandon your body complete the girl
she's lost no matter what now that he
has just oh my God this looks so good
oh you're gonna be kidding me
dude
oh my gosh
well I'm stoked
March 24th I think we knew that maybe
I'm unsure
all right I'm very glad that the
comments seem to be saying the same
thing
um
mostly I don't care but I do kind of
about this one
where he's doing what's happening gonna
be the greatest game ever I've completed
Ari for a ton of times and I can just
say Capcom absolutely knocked it out of
the park this looks absolutely
outstanding
it really really really does look good
it's very pretty
I mean it's got to be one of the most
iconic games ever made and you really
could screw it up but I'm like it's so
comforting to be very very confident
that they won't screw it up it's just
really nice
seems like the plague inside Leon and
Ashley will play a bigger role excited
to see what comes of it yeah it for sure
notice that
it's like an interesting choice to like
very specifically highlight that
um uh what what
okay this comment is a pretty good point
Daniel Cooper said I'm super high fiery
full but won't allow the trailer symbol
my expectations I remember the trailer
for re3 made folk believe Jill's Trauma
from the Mansion would be a plot line
based on the trailer showing her in the
mirror as a zombie as well we saw how
relevant that was to the story and that
is true that is
a pretty good point yeah it is awesome
man it I'm so glad that doing this like
a lot of shade of remakes lately but I
don't know I feel like I I'm loving the
Resident Evil remix I'm also loving what
they do for the industry in terms of
proving that this genre can sell because
there was definitely a notion among AAA
for a while that survival horror games
or horror games in general wouldn't sell
um like the closure of
um what's the name of the studio that
made Dead Space
I'm sadly forgetting the name of The
Studio Life comes at you fast when you
get shut down
um but I feel like the success of these
games of the uh e-mix as it were has
kind of like reignited that which is
awesome and yeah this one is just very
very cool seeing
you know a lot of this really really
iconic stuff I mean this shot where he's
just this this here obviously like
an incredibly iconic part of video game
history in general a very exciting part
of the game
um but seeing it look this way
oh I'm very excited okay that's the
first one down next up adjustment next
up is the Resident Evil reverse launch
Trail and make sure we're in HD we are
okay let's do it Mission adjustment
no doesn't change anything
[Music]
doing nothing but recon's got me
up let's have some fun people
move out
yes okay
foreign
that's pretty sick
[Music]
something playing this Jack is so funny
[Music]
so it's been a long wait for Ari bus and
this is not like that much of a trailer
but we have already seen a Fitbit at the
game so I'm all right with it I played
the beta a few years back and it was fun
but like
nothing special but yeah this is clearly
just a really fast is a real well
I don't know yet it's free it's cool
we'll see how I feel when we we get to
actually play it
um okay so last is a Resident Evil
Village Gold Edition story trailer which
yeah I'll have gameplay up up soon I'm
I'm excited about it
[Music]
be half birthday Rose
I just want to find my daughter
I'll always be there for you no matter
what
nothing does look really cool
kind of weird
You Are My Precious Rose
and I didn't care
so long as we were together
hmm
okay I was like surprised we didn't see
more about but there's still a minute
left it's okay
it's mostly just a recap so far
I think we even saw that
[Music]
sometimes
it's super cool
try to imagine what he might have said
to me
no matter
your imminent demise
inevitable no I love him so much you're
a huge fan
I love you but I won't let anything
happen to Rose
I've got this
definitely very unique Vibes for
Resident Evil with the
magicy stuff
[Music]
um but I think just a great poll in
general to go back to Oh The Game's out
really soon anyway I only have a data
really
um to to go back to
Castle dimitrisk which is one of my
favorite parts of the game
um I feel like the the first third of
actually every Resident Evil probably
[ __ ] the first third of Ari Village and
re7 uh particularly were like so so so
good not that the games went good
overall I enjoyed both of them but just
like absolute bangers from the start
um all right let's jump over to whatever
is up with Silent Hill
um I really have virtually no idea I
just saw some
people tweeting vague [ __ ] and then
stopped paying attention so not fully
shovel or info let's find out okay full
conference is 48 minutes we have
I'm not even I'm not looking at the
titles one two three four five videos
five there are there five Silent Hill
games
I'm I'm trying not to look at any of it
we're just gonna we're just gonna browse
right through it and say as spoiler free
as possible
the title is unavoidable this one is
Silent Hill two teaser trailer so
um
my question is is it like a silent hill
two part two or is it just a Silent Hill
2 remake
[Music]
I mean that looks very good
could she really be here
waiting for me
oh I wonder if this is what blooper is
making
Mary died of that damn disease three
years ago
in my Restless dreams
see that town God this is just making me
think about how good of a game Silent
Hill 2 is
foreign
what a [ __ ] good video game
oh that's awesome it is the Bluebird
game okay glad to see that um uh Akira
is on the the music
I know what you are
I know why I needed you
honestly this whole time I'm just
thinking about how good the original is
not that this doesn't look good but it's
it's kind of hard to say like I don't
I have played every Bluebird Team game I
do really like them
um I mean if I don't think any of them
is a 10 out of 10. oh my God that looks
good
I do think that they're fun for how
unique they are
but if they're just remaking
Silent Hill 2 that's a very different
thing that
I feel like their chances of success are
pretty high I don't know
just like Notch I'm ready being on board
with Konami I don't know
[Music]
dude this looks beautiful Mary
oh my God it's like so much scarier
oh good graphics
is there a release date you know a
window at all
no it is Unreal Engine
okay okay
um
again
just repeatedly I kept just like
stopping and being like damn Silent Hill
2 is good
um
I don't actually think that Silent Hill
2 is a game that needs to be remade
and you could say that of Resident Evil
4 as well
um
again I really like what resident Evil's
doing because they're making them so
different this
I don't know I don't know that that like
Silent Hill 2 still it really does hold
up in my opinion I feel the same way
about dead space actually I think the
Dead Space remake is even less necessary
on the other hand though I'm like happy
to
have the story of Silent Hill and like
Silent Hill 2 specifically and what it
is continue for new players who maybe
didn't play Silent Hill 2 when it first
came out because it was so important in
the era that it came out to like the
cost and even the graphics like
everything for the time that it came out
was just so beautifully packaged
um but I don't know if it has that charm
and it maybe it's harder to encourage
people to go back to it so I'm happy
that this is happening
cautiously optimistic
cautiously optimistic not sold
in either direction
just reminded of how [ __ ] good Silent
Hill 2 is
Silent Hill townful no idea what this is
why are you here
no in this place why are you here
so impressed by that imagery beautiful
dude
that's good I like it
you know what I think you're right
I mean we've done something so awful
we are stuck here in this place
being judged by these people
but for you
I think it's more than that
I love this
it's so stylish
and I don't want to be anyone here
what is it though
it's made by the studio I believe
um
if I'm remembering correctly that made
um alien isolation
which I mean
that game certainly has a fantastic
grasp
on atmosphere sound design
how to restrict and place resources to
stress you the [ __ ] out I'm actually
glad again if I'm correct about them
being that the dev um apologies if I've
messed that up then I'm glad that they
would be doing this that's cool uh even
if it's not team silent it's like again
kind of like cautiously optimistic um
but ultimately don't know what it is
this this trailer kind of has control
Vibes actually okay next up is Silent
Hill Ascension
I don't think I've heard of this either
multiplayer twitch integrated thing
I wonder if it's gonna be like a dead by
daylight
nice work with the synth though
the live 2023 faced her trauma together
so little information
okay let's go to ascension.com
maybe this one
in 2021 we released the Executioner and
the Survivor Cheryl Mason in dead by
daylight okay today Behavior once again
will dive into the world of Silent Hill
but with a completely new experience
okay dead by daylight sorry
creative of our service division to tell
you all about it everyone at behavior is
excited to announce our collaboration
with genvid on silent hill Ascension in
a new form of entertainment that blends
Community Live storytelling and
interactivity
on a unique interactive storytelling
experience where the decisions you make
affect the characters and the world
those decisions become Canon and there's
no reset button this is a whole new
chapter for Silent Hill it's a new
characters and frightful monsters where
the stakes couldn't be more real
we're thrilled to be working with The
Talented teams at genvid Bad Robot and
dj2 to bring Silent Hill Ascension to
life look for it to go live in 2023 and
sign up at ascension.com for updates
in 20. okay need to see more don't know
okay what is Silent Hill
f
I'm intrigued
dude these trailers have been really
good this is so like cinematic and
Moody and the colors and damn
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is some very vivid imagery oh oh
[Music]
it always gives me like gross chills
very mid-summer
[Music]
I feel like I've seen this before that
wasn't
one of the leaks
okay
I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
who's making it
[Music]
neobots it will be a completely new
story set in 1960 Japan featuring a
beautiful yet horrifying World Japanese
visual novels dealing murder mysteries
psychological supernatural horror that's
very cool I mean I I'm not familiar with
his work but it sounds like people like
it um
this was really cool but
don't really know what it is it yeah I
mean a very interesting trailer at the
very least like super interested in that
to be honest
um how do I feel about this overall I
think uh
like confused I'm I'm I'm super excited
that this new Silent Hill stuff for the
most part like I'm excited and happy to
hear about that but I I don't I don't
know how like I don't know if I'm
I'm excited conceptually but not like in
practice like I I um everything is is
cautiously optimistic for me right now
for sure definitely like a we'll see you
know we'll see I'm glad that there's
more coming
uh I certainly hope it's good different
stuff definitely um we skipped over the
movie trailer just because
I skipped through a little bit of it
when I realized that Silent Hill was a
more of an interview thing than them
actually showing a trailer and it's just
a little bit longer so I didn't cover
that but glad it's the same director he
does seem to be really faithful to the
franchise
it's I'm just like feeling sort of
tricks like I don't know what to think
right now hey
great time to be a survival horror fan
keep it up